business leaders as you know are also
criticizing the president's response
five members of his American
manufacturing council have resigned
since Monday including the CEOs of Merck
and Under Armour the latest to leave the
council is Richard Trumka he is
president of the afl-cio that's the
country's largest Federation of labor
unions Trumka said he resigned quote on
behalf of America's working people who
reject all notions of legitimacy of
these bigoted groups only on CBS this
morning Richard Trumka joins us from
Pittsburgh good morning to you mr. Trump
thank you for taking the time today
listening thanks for having me on you
made it clear on Sunday that you were
not happy you called on the president at
that time to call the violence in
Charlottesville domestic terrorism
rooted in bigotry but you didn't resign
from the council until yesterday what
did you hear yesterday that made you say
okay that's enough I'm out well the the
labor movement has four long forever
been at the tip of the spear in ending
racism and bigotry we think it's not
acceptable to even tolerate racism and
bigotry let alone defend it encourage it
or aiding and abetting yesterday the the
president's statement really unveiled
his true feelings about this situation
in Charlottesville and around the
country and it was unacceptable was
Richard rich which one got to you which
one his spirited defense of of racism
and bigotry the ultra-right nash white
nationalism neo-nazis and the KKK when
he tried to put equal blame on both
sides when these organizations that
their stamina at their core are based on
racism and bigotry that's unacceptable
that's a none American value and when he
gave that defense of them and sort of
put a pox on everybody's house it became
too much for us to be associated with
that so the the the issue of the the
manufacturing council was separate quite
frankly from the the symbolism of being
associated with it we the council itself
is
be ineffective it's never met it's a
subterfuge to be able to deregulate
industry so that's totally separate but
it's the symbolism of being associated
with it that we rejected yesterday so
you're saying you're going through the
American manufacturing Council never met
it's never done anything no it's never
met are you hoping other leaders will
step down Richard
well I think they have to have their
conscience and they have to have follow
their conscience
I followed our conscience and what our
what our American did the labor movement
believes in we believe it's unacceptable
to aid in a bet or even tolerate any
group that's founded on racism and
biggest one we should be fighting
against that and eliminating that and
and we decided that we wanted to get off
of that but here's the second question
they ought ask themselves okay so now
they get off the council but will they
accept all the benefits of that council
after it confers them oh here's my
question really if you're really
standing by your convictions you would
do both here's my question for you after
a sense that the president was committed
to making creating more jobs and you had
met with him do are you now urging all
labor members to withdraw their support
to this president because of the views
he reflected in that press conference
yesterday look we didn't support the
president in the election but after the
election we thought we had an obligation
to for the country and to and to workers
and to my members to try to come
together where we could and we
identified a couple of places you know
was infrastructure it was manufacturing
it was trade where we could actually
come together and do some good if we can
can in the future if we can work
together to get things done there we'll
continue to do that but we will reject
and continue to reject any notion of
legitimacy for groups like the white
nationalist the Ku Klux Klan and other
like-minded groups because we don't see
any legitimacy to a group
that his father founding principle is
racism and bigotry but is it a stain on
the presidency for this president to say
what he said on Saturday entered into
reinforce it yesterday yeah it was
shocking to me yeah
and what did what he did was I think it
gives them legitimacy that they're not
entitled to
he also said yesterday Richard he also
said this that by giving people more
jobs that would help end racism what did
you make of that
I think he's confusing issues because if
jobs are created but people are excluded
because of the way they look or who they
worship or who they love they're
eliminated then those jobs are beyond
their reach we're all about creating
jobs and opportunity for everybody so
that regardless of what you look like
where you came from who you worship or
who you love you have an equal
opportunity and a fair chance to let
your abilities take you everywhere that
they can his statements yesterday were
shocking and quite frankly I thought to
myself you know I
I'll pray for you I'll pray for you
because you really need to be prayed for
when you make those kinds of statements
Richard there are dozens of other
well-respected executives that sit on
these councils are you also urging them
to step down I think they have to follow
their own conscience we did what we
thought was right
they should do what they think is right
and we believed that the symbolism of
being associated with that spirited
defense of racism and bigotry was just
unacceptable
all right Richard Trumka we thank you
very much for joining us this morning
thank you thanks for having me on I
really appreciate it we do too